>> Stephen: WELCOME TO "THE
REPORT"!
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US, LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN, IN HERE, OUT
THERE, ALL AROUND THE WORLD,
NATION, HUGE SHOW TONIGHT!
I AM EITHER VERY HAPPY ABOUT THE
EMMYS OR WONDERING WHY I WENT.
(LAUGHTER)
EITHER WAY, I CANNOT WAIT TO
FIND OUT HOW I AM SO HUNG OVER.
OH, EXCUSE ME, HOLD ON A SECOND.
MY STOUFFER FROZEN DINNER IS
READY!
AND, OH, KIDS! THERE'S NOTHING I
ENJOY MORE
THAN EATING A NICE, HOT
STOUFFER'S FAMILY-SIZE LASAGNA.
I MAY NOT BE A WHOLE FAMILY, BUT
AFTER THIS, I WILL FEEL LIKE
I'VE GOT A BABY IN ME!
(LAUGHTER)
AND THE REASON I'M STOUFFIN' MY
FACE IS THIS COMPANY HAILS FROM
THE 78th INSTALLMENT OF MY
434 PART SERIES, BETTER KNOW A
DISTRICT. TONIGHT, OHIO'S 11TH,
THE FIGHTING 11TH!
OHIO'S 11th, INCLUDES THE CITY
OF CLEVELAND, FOUNDED BY GENERAL
MOSES CLEVELAND IN 1796.
AS OF 1800 THE CITY'S
POPULATION CONSISTED OF ONLY
THREE MEN -- A SOCIOLOGICAL
CONDITION KNOWN TODAY AS
NORTH DAKOTA.
IN 1879, CLEVELAND BECAME THE
WORLD'S FIRST CITY TO BE LIGHTED
ELECTRICALLY.
RESIDENTS WERE PROUD OF THE
ACHIEVEMENT, THOUGH DISAPPOINTED
TO SEE MORE OF CLEVELAND.
(LAUGHTER)
THE 11th IS HOME TO THE MIGHTY
CUHAHOGA RIVER, ONCE SO
POLLUTED, IT SPURRED THE
CREATION OF THE EPA AFTER
CATCHING ON FIRE 13 TIMES.
AFTER THE FIRST 12 FIRES THEY
REALIZED THEY SHOULDN'T TRY TO
PUT THEM OUT WITH RIVER WATER.
IN 1935, THE DISTRICT WAS THE
FIRST PLACE OF ALCOHOLICS
ANONYMOUS FOUNDED BY BILL WILSON
AND DR. BOB SMITH.
OH, SHOOT!
FOUNDED BY TWO GUYS.
SORRY.
(LAUGHTER)
OKAY.
OHIO'S 11th IS THE HOME OF THE
CAVALIERS, THE BROWNS AND THE
CLEVELAND INDIANS, A TEAM SO BAD
THAT THEY ARE IN LAST PLACE AT
OFFENDING NATIVE AMERICANS.
(LAUGHTER)
THE ROCK AND ROLL HALL OF FAME
IN CLEVELAND ATTRACTS HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF TOURISTS TO THE
11th EACH YEAR.
THIS YEAR THE HALL INDUCTED
'70s ROCK BAND KISS WHOSE
FRONT MAN GENE SIMMONS IS THE
ONLY THING MORE POLLUTED
THAN THE CUYAHOGA RIVER.
AND WHO HAS THE CLEVELAND ROCKS
TO REPRESENT THE DISTRICT?
IT'S NONE OTHER THAN
CONGRESSWOMAN MARTHA FUDGE THE
HEAD OF THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK
CAUCUS.
I SAT DOWN WITH REPRESENTATIVE
FUDGE IN HER WASHINGTON OFFICE.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TALKING TO ME.
>> MY PLEASURE.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Stephen: TELL ME ABOUT THE
FIGHTING 11th.
>> THE 11th, THOUGH MY OPINION
IS PROBABLY BIASED, IS THE BEST
IN THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE THE BEST ORCHESTRA, THE
BEST HEALTHCARE WITH THE
CLEVELAND CLINIC, UNIVERSITY
HOSPITALS AND --
>> Stephen: LeBRON, AM
I RIGHT?
UP TOP?
>> LeBRON.
>> Stephen: UP TOP?
YOU MUST BE EXCITED HE'S
RETURNING TO CLEVELAND.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Stephen: YOU MUST BE PRETTY
EXCITED WHEN ANYONE IS RETURNING
TO CLEVELAND.
>> I AM EXCITED HE'S COMING BACK
TO CLEVELAND, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Stephen: YOUR DISTRICT IS
HOME TO MICELI DAIRY PRODUCTS
AND YOU ALSO HOST AN ANNUAL
LEMONADE STAND DAY
AND YOU WERE BORN
IN YOUR DISTRICT?
>> YES.
>> Stephen: IS IT ACCURATE TO
SAY MILK, MILK, LEMONADE,
AROUND THE CORNER FUDGE IS MADE?
(LAUGHTER)
>> I GUESS, YES.
>> Stephen: OKAY, I DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE THAT PHRASE CAME FROM
CLEVELAND IS KNOWN FOR ITS
FANTASTIC HEALTHCARE.
>> CORRECT.
THE CLEVELAND CLINIC IS THE
SITE OF THE WORLD'S FIRST FACE
TRANSPLANT.
>> YES.
>> Stephen: HOW DO I KNOW YOU
ARE MARTHA FUDGE?
PERHAPS SOMEONE STOLE YOUR FACE,
PUT IT ON THEIR BODY AND
IS NOW HERE TO REPRESENT
THEMSELVES AS MARTHA FUDGE
THE CLEVELAND CLINIC HAS MADE
THAT A REALITY
>> I'VE HAD THIS FACE A LONG
TIME.
A LOT OF PEOPLE KNOW ME.
>> Stephen: LET ME ASK YOUR
OPINION.
>> OKAY.
>> Stephen: DO YOU THINK I
SHOULD JUST GET A FRESHEN UP
OR GET A WHOLE TEAR-DOWN AND
HAVE A NEW ONE PUT ON.
>> I THINK YOU LOOK FINE.
>> Stephen: I'M THINKING JUST
A LITTLE, LIKE THIS.
JUST, HI! I'VE JUST BEEN
SLEEPING A LOT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> I THINK YOU LOOK GREAT.
>> Stephen: REALLY?
YES.
>> Stephen: THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ANOTHER
SUBJECT.
WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT CHILDREN
FROM EL SALVADOR AND GUATAMALA
AND HONDURAS WHO ARE COMING TO
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER IN DROVES?
>> I THINK WE SHOULD FOLLOW THE
LAW AND THE LAW SAYS THAT WE
HAVE TO GIVE THEM A DUE PROCESS
HEARING AND DETERMINE IF, IN
FACT, THEY SHOULD BE SENT BACK
OR IF THEY CAN STAY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Stephen: THE LAW ALSO SAYS
TO PROTECT OUR BORDERS.
>> IT DOES AND WE DO.
>> Stephen: HOW SO?
THEY'RE GETTING ACROSS, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF THESE KIDS, IF THEY
ARE KIDS.
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW IF THEY ARE
CHILDREN.
GUATEMALAIANS ARE VERY WONDERFUL
BUT VERY SMALL PEOPLE
(LAUGHTER)
ANY ONE OF THEM COULD BE ADULTS
WEARING A KID'S SUIT.
>> WE PUT LAWS IN PLACE FOR A
REASON.
THE 2008 LAW SIGNED BY PRESIDENT
GEORGE BUSH NEEDS TO BE
ENFORCED.
>> Stephen: YOU FOUGHT FOR
IMMIGRATION REFORM TO INCLUDE
IMMIGRANTS FROM AFRICA.
WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO DO THAT?
WE TRIED THAT FOR 300 YEARS AND
IT WAS TERRIBLE FOR BOTH SIDES
TO BRING ALL THOSE IMMIGRANTS
OVER HERE
(LAUGHTER)
LED TO A HUGE PROBLEM.
LED TO A WAR.
>> IT WAS OVER SLAVERY.
>> Stephen: YOU'RE SAYING THE
WAR WASN'T OVER SLAVERY.
>> YES.
>> Stephen: IT WAS?
BUT IT WASN'T NECESSARILY
BECAUSE PEOPLE FROM AFRICA WERE
TRYING TO COME ACROSS OUR
BORDERS AS IMMIGRANTS.
WE WERE BROUGHT HERE AGAINST OUR
OWN WILL.
>> Stephen: WELL, HISTORY WILL
BE THE JUDGE.
(LAUGHTER)
SPEAKING OF PEOPLE OF COLOR.
JOHN BOEHNER.
YOU HELD HANDS WITH MITCH
MCCONNELL AND JOHN BOEHNER
AND SANG WE SHALL OVERCOME
RIGHT? TO COMMEMORATE THE
1964 CIVIL RIGHTS ACT
>> YES.
>> Stephen: RACISM IS OVER,
RIGHT?
>> NO, IT IS NOT.
>> Stephen: HOW COULD YOU HAVE
DONE THAT IF THERE WAS STILL
RACISM?
>> IT SAYS WE SHALL, AT SOME
POINT WE WILL.
>> Stephen: ♪♪ WE HAVE OVERCOME.
♪♪
JOIN ME.
♪ WE HAVE OVERCOME
♪ WE HAVE OVERCOME ALBEIT
RECENTLY ♪♪
THINGS HAVE GOTTEN BETTER.
>> YES.
>> Stephen: WHEN YOU LOOK BACK
AT THE MOST EGREGIOUS PART OF
RACISM, JIM CROW ERA, '50s,
'60s, IS THERE ANY PART OF IT
THAT YOU MISS?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Stephen: OKAY. MAY I?
THE DRINKING FOUNTAINS.
DON'T GET ME WRONG, I DON'T
THINK THERE SHOULD BE WHITE OR
BLACK DRINKING FOUNTAINS.
ANYONE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DRINK
FROM ANY THEY WANT.
BUT THERE WERE TWICE AS MANY
DRINKING FOUNTAINS
IT WAS JUST MORE CONVENIENT, YOU
KNOW.
>> I DON'T THINK DRINKING
FOUNTAINS ARE THE MOST SANITARY
THING ANYWAY.
>> Stephen: SO YOUR BIGGEST
PROBLEM WITH THOSE
IS THAT THEY'RE UNSANITARY?
>> NO, MY BIGGEST PROBLEM IS
THAT THERE WERE
WHITE FOUNTAINS
AND BLACK FOUNTAINS.
>> Stephen: IF YOU DON'T WANT
TO USE EITHER ONE, WHY IS IT A
PROBLEM?
>> IT RESTRICTED MOVEMENT IN OUR
NATION.
>> Stephen: I AGREE. YOU AND I
ARE
SINGING THE SAME TUNE HERE,
ALTHOUGH WITH DIFFERENT LYRICS.
(LAUGHTER)
CLEVELAND IS THE HOME TO THE
ROCK AND ROLL HALL OF FAME. CAN
YOU GET ME IN?
>> YES.
>> Stephen: I HAVE TWO
GRAMMIES.
I HAD A BAND IN THE '80s
CALLED STEPHEN AND THE COLBERTS.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THE SONG "I'M
RIGHT BEHIND YOU NOW, CHARLENE"
>> I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH, NO.
♪ EVERY TIME I SEE YOU, I THINK
OF YOU ♪
♪ EVERY TIME I'M NEAR YOU, I
THINK OF YOU ♪
♪ I THINK OF YOU WHEN I DREAM OF
YOU ♪
♪ AND I'M TAKING PICTURES OF
♪ I THINK OF YOU WHEN I'M IN A
BLIMP ♪
♪ LOOK HING DOWN FROM UP ABOVE
YOU ♪
♪ YOU KNOW I'M MISSING YOU
♪ MY MIND IS KISSING YOU
♪ I'M RIGHT BEHIND YOU NOW,
CHARLENE ♪♪
(LAUGHTER)
♪
♪ I'M RIGHT BEHIND YOU NOW,
CHARLENE ♪♪
♪♪ YOU'LL NEVER BE ALONE AGAIN,
NO ♪♪
(LAUGHTER)
>> Stephen: THAT DOESN'T RING
A BELL AT ALL?
IT DOESN'T --
>> ARE WE DONE?
PLEASE.
>> Stephen: NO, WE'RE NOT
DONE!
STAY TUNED FOR THE EXCITING
CONCLUSION OF THIS THING WE'RE
NOT DONE WITH.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK!